uh you Canada has recently decided to
agree to Germany's request to send a
guest turbine back we're learning now
that this is a deal that will last for
two years it could involve multiple gas
turbines but going back and forth
President zielinski says that this is
unacceptable what do you say to him what
do you say to the Ukrainian people what
do you say the Ukrainian Canadian
Congress who is now taking you to court
over it when you say you stand with
Ukraine is are there no other options
Canada has been one of the strongest
countries in the world in standing with
Ukraine in being there to support
president zielinski and the heroic
fighting that people in Ukraine are
doing not just to defend their Homeland
against an illegal unjustifiable
horrific Invasion by Russia but they're
also standing up for the values and
principles that that underlie
our democracies and the rule of law and
territorial integrity and sovereignty so
yes Canada will continue to be there
unequivocally to stand with Ukraine
so this was a very difficult decision
but we have seen
Russia
consistently trying to weaponize energy
as a way of creating division amongst
the allies
of undermining the general population's
support
for this essential effort in Ukraine
that governments continue to support
and I remind people that the sanctions
that Canada is leading on that that we
continue to push harder and harder are
aimed at Putin and his enablers
and aren't designed to harm our allies
and their populations
this decision
to
be there to support Germany and Europe
in the real challenges they face around
energy particularly over the coming year
as they work as fast as they can to get
off the Reliance of Russian oil and gas
is an essential piece in ensuring that
not just governments across Europe and
around the world but populations in our
countries continue
to support their governments
stepping up with billions of dollars of
support in Military and financial and
humanitarian support for the Ukrainian
people while they lead this essential
fight against tyranny and oppression
like I said Canada remains one of the
strongest allies to Ukraine friends to
Ukraine we have been there with economic
support in the billions of dollars
significant Armament we continue to but
we're not alone
countries in Europe particularly Germany
have stepped up massively in their
support of Ukraine as well and we need
to hold together particularly faced with
the
attempts by Russia to weaponize energy
policy
to divide us amongst ourselves
we will continue to stand up ever
stronger sanctions but remember that
those sanctions are aimed not at our
allies but at Putin and his cronies
and that's exactly why we took this
difficult decision
to be there for our allies to ensure
that in Europe not just governments but
populations stay steadfast and generous
in their support of Ukraine and of the
extremely important fight that President
zielinski and ukrainians are leading not
just to defend their own territory but
to defend the underpinnings of our
democracies